okay so II cycling it's you riding a
stationary bicycle in a virtual world
competing against other people and let's
be honest it's probably not the weirdest
eSport you've ever heard of the British
Cycling Association got involved and
decided to create a national
championship and the guy that won that
first national championship has just
been banned for six months fined roughly
$400 in stripped of his gold medal for
robo doping yeah I wish I was kidding
[Music]
okay so first of all I refuse to accept
that robo doping is a [ __ ] thing I
mean what was he injecting the game into
his veins Josh took a trip my friend
anyways the program or game that you
racing is called Swift and it's a
mash-up of crazy virtual volcanoes in
real-world locations and the youtuber
found guilty of cheating is Cameron
Jeffers he frequently uploads content to
YouTube around cycling in the UK now you
might be asking yourself how does one
cheat in a cycling well just hold on a
sec we're gonna get there I promise now
apparently you can unlock a bunch of
different bikes to race with and Swift
the best being the Tron bike
[Applause]
not only does it glow apparently it's
the fastest bike in the game and gives
you an objective advantage during
competition now to unlock it you have to
I mean you can probably guess bike up
and down a whole hell of a lot of a
virtual mountain that's while selecting
the Everest challenge and rotting past
eight thousand nine hundred meters all
the way up to 50 kilometers of quanti
now that youtuber Cameron Jeffers said
[ __ ] that and in December of 2018 got
somebody to do it for him using bot
software that simulated the necessary
distance in order to unlock the bike so
you know this person logged into my
account used in ampulla simulator which
essentially just put in like a power
value for example at four hundred whilst
click enter I'm your avatar than the
game will just sit at 400 watts about
what you haven't to pedal so Jeffers
placed 12th at the British Cycling
erasing Championship qualifier and the
only reason he got into the top 10 and
the grand finals is because two dudes
randomly dropped out nice eSport you got
that I guess you're the winner by
default default the two sweetest words
in the English language these both
anyways Jeffers won the whole
championship in March in front of a live
studio audience then an April Jeffers
received a letter from the British
Cycling whatever that states because he
illegally obtained this Tron bike he's
being stripped of his metal band for six
months and roughly find $400 now just so
we're clear about this Jeffers and
everybody else was using the Tron bike
in this race which means he had no
discernible advantage now apparently the
biking people got tipped off about all
these shenanigans and an anonymous email
and Jeffers doesn't know who could have
sent it well I mean Jeffers couldn't it
have been the dude who rigged this [ __ ]
for you in the first place I don't know
just a thought now to be very clear
Jeffers does admit that he gave somebody
access to his account and they screwed
with the numbers a little bit and
illegally got him the Tron bike I'm the
one that all the blame should be
directed to and yeah it's all on me so
it doesn't matter who this was
he didn't even win that much money
roughly $650 and a tiny ass zip up
Hoodie that some dude gave to him when
he was standing on top of the podium so
this is a super serious punishment for a
nice boy
that's billing itself as digital cycling
I mean players have to adhere to an
anti-doping policy there's a strict way
in policy before the event even begins
but then on the other hand you can roll
over power-ups like it's [ __ ] Mario
Cart so not only are the power-ups
randomly distributed throughout the race
they come with weird-ass names like
burrito which makes you undrafted Bowl
for 10 seconds why they chose burrito I
have no earthly idea then there's ghosts
which makes you [ __ ] invisible to
other riders and feather which makes you
virtually lighter despite the fact that
there are strict weigh-in policies
before the race even begins in a
competitive eSport how are the
randomized power-ups what does it smash
with items on your look at the shield
pressure whoa whoa look at all this
damage man even stacking gigantic bales
of hay sounds better than this [ __ ] but
slow Fabio could oh this is intro come
on top of that Jeffers states that he
cheated long before the furnace
Association of whatever wrote the rules
for this championship which means
according to him he technically didn't
do anything wrong
the the erasin rules rulebook was wrote
on the 9th of March 2019 this was you
know months after I'd actually done a
sample simulation so at the time of
doing it you know whether it was morally
right or wrong now I think into it if
we're talking from a technical stunts
and it was I didn't break any erasing
rules because there was none to be
broken anyways in this YouTube apology
video Jeffers is upset about the ruling
but he's going to accept it except that
he's not because he's hired a lawyer to
try to get him out of it you know I
decided to employ a solicitor to fight
my case just because of how passionate I
was about to and get this last week
Swift announced the first ever cycling
eSports World Championships to take
place in 2020
this comes with sanctioning from the UCI
which is the IOC sanctioning body for
everything bicycle racing related so
there's a chance you could see this
goofy [ __ ] power-ups and all in the 2024
Olympics thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]